نحن ننظر تحديدًا في كيفية دخول
الألياف الدقيقة ذات الطبيعة البلاستيكية
إلى المحيط ، وأحد
أكبر مصادر ذلك هو غسيل
[الموسيقى]
، حيث يتم استخدام حوالي 40 مليون طن من
الألياف الاصطناعية هنا كل عام إذا
كانت  تعتبر صناعة النسيج
مادة رائعة لصنع الملابس ،
ولكن هناك عواقب فقط عندما يكون
هناك مواد بلاستيكية وتلك المتانة
التي تجعل الملابس رائعة تجعل من
الصعب للغاية تحطيم الجدران للوصول
إلى الكمية ، فهذا يعني أنك فقط
تعرف متوسط ملابسك الرياضية.  حت
100 بالمائة من البوليستر يمكننا استخدام
هذه الأقمشة لاختبار مجموعة من
دورات الغسيل المختلفة لمعرفة
أي من هذه الدورات يطلق معظم
الألياف ، لذا يبدو أن
[موسيقى]
لا يقدر الناس ذلك حقًا
المشكلة التي تحدث
يجب أن نكون قادرين على تطوير صور
وصور لما يحدث حتى نتمكن من
إظهار للجمهور ما يحدث
نسيج بوليستر
مكبّر هذا ما تراه كل هذه
يمكن لآلاف الألياف التي يتم غسلها
أن تتلاشى أثناء الملابس وإلى
محطات معالجة مياه الصرف الصحي وفي
النهاية تحت المحيط إذا بدأت
في النظر إلى تأثيرات هذه
القطع الصغيرة من البلاستيك على
الكائنات الدقيقة جدًا من البكتيريا الأولية والعوالق
في محيطاتنا ، فربما يكون لديهم  ربما يكون هناك
تأثير أكثر ضررًا على هذه
الكائنات الدقيقة عن طريق
التراكم وابتلاع
المواد البلاستيكية التي تمر عبر السلسلة الغذائية التي
لا يعرفها أحد حقًا ونحتاج إلى
معرفة
ذلك ، فما يهمنا هو العثور
على انتشار ووفرة البلاستيك
داخل ذلك  العوالق ، هذه يرقات سرطان البحر
، يبلغ طولها حوالي 1 مليمتر ، ما
يمكننا رؤيته هو البلاستيك الذي تم
ابتلاعه بواسطة العوالق الحيوانية التي
وجدت كل شيء هناك
[موسيقى] ،
لذا فهو علم مبكر بدأنا للتو
في تجربة التأثيرات المحتملة
لهذه  قد تكون موجودة في جميع
مستويات الحياة ، بما في ذلك نحن ، أعتقد
أنها مشكلة يجب علينا جميعًا أن ننظر
فيها إلى مصنعي المنظفات "
صانعي الغسالات هم
نحن شخصيًا وكيف نبدأ في شراء
الملابس وغسل الملابس
[موسيقى]
اختيار الدورة مهم
جدًا ، لذا لمحاولة استخدام الدورات السريعة الباردة ،
يجب أن أتجنب دورات الغسيل الدقيقة تلك
وتجنب الغسيل الصغير  تستخدم كميات كبيرة من
الملابس غسالات عالية الكفاءة ،
وجدنا ملابس جديدة أكثر من تلك التي كانت
تتساقط من الألياف أكثر بكثير من
جميع الأقمشة التي تخبر المستهلكين
بطريقة أخرى يمكنهم من خلالها
تقليل كمية الألياف بشكل كبير وهي شراء
ملابس جديدة أقل تعرفها الميكروباصات
بيئتنا  من الصعب حقًا
إزالتها ، لذا فهم كيف يمكننا
القيام بخطوات صغيرة لمنع المزيد
من المواد البلاستيكية الدقيقة من دخول المحيط